bonsoir pedro gonesse neto merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france cet accord
répondrai donc aux exigences de
washington qui souhaitait que les
activités américaines de tik tok soient
contrôlés par les américains est ce que
ce sera le cas alors on dans les faits
il faut savoir que tik tok ni moins la
version utilisée par l'occident et à la
base on va dire une société américaine
qui était musical y est donc
jusqu'à maintenant les chinois
effectivement avait investi énormément
dans la chatte cette entreprise mais le
coeur opérationnelle de l'entreprise a
toujours été aux états unis
effectivement il n'y a rien à redire et
tous les lire spécialisé la technologie
avait rien qui pouvait attester une
quelconque surveillance réel des réseaux
via tik tok surtout que dans les faits
on peut se poser la question si des
adolescentes de 12 ans qui dans son croc
top représente un réel risque pour la
sécurité des états unis
dans tous les cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que pour d'autres c'est une victoire il
montre qu'il était pillé la chine son
grand ennemi que il arrive à créer une
multitude d'emplois aux états unis ce
qui reste quand même trouver parce que
25000 emplois surtout dans un secteur de
technologie sert à rien et à ce que je
sache tic n'est pas une entreprise qui
génère autant de revenus ça génère des
revenus mais surtout la plupart de ces
revenus sont générés par les différentes
levée de fonds dont pas forcément par
son chiffre d'affaires
mais effectivement pour lui ça va
permettre dans le cadre de la campagne
électorale de pouvoir dire regardez j'ai
fait piller chinois j'ai obtenu des
emplois pour les américains
et donc à la son adversaire de maiden
qu'est ce que vous vous proposez en face
et c'est vrai que là dessus c'est une
vie c'était une victoire assez facile
mais sur lequel je pense qu'il va
vouloir capitaliser un maximum c'est pas
tout à fait encore conclue mais est ce
que le gouvernement chinois lui a son
mot à dire qu'au mieux comme le fait le
président américain entre nous je pense
que le chinois n'ont strictement rien à
faire c'est à dire pour eux la seule
chose c'est qu'ils veulent pas être
perdant commercialement en lait
les chinois comme beaucoup de fonds de
beaucoup pays investissent dans des
multitudes de sociétés technologiques
via leurs multitudes de corporations
qu'ils ont déjà
et effectivement il fondit peuvent
acheter aussi bien un fondeur de
processeurs ce que fait d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui l'entreprise nvidia avec la
société anglaise armes c'est à dire
qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
étrangères achètent des sociétés à
l'étranger sans que cela puisse vraiment
posé de problème chances que les chinois
la seule chose c'est qu'ils ne veulent
pas dire être accusé à tort de faire de
l'espionnage d'avoir une mauvaise image
mais ils ont prouvé dans le passé qu'ils
étaient très bon pour les affaires et je
pense que pour eux effectivement ils
sont plutôt dans l'optique de se
débarrasser de quelque chose qui gêne
leur image de marque plutôt qu'
effectivement de se maintenir quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui concrètement si on
se place d'un point de vue absolue
la valeur des tic toc même si c'est
valoriser je crois 60 milliards etc
ça reste très discutable et on a vu dans
le passé des myspace etc qui va l'aider
fortunés qui aujourd'hui ne valent plus
rien donc la prochaine génération on
n'est pas du tout sûr que les tice
tictoc vers on le voit avec le cas de
facebook qui était très valorisé qui
aujourd'hui les jeunes générations ne
vont plus sur facebook il ya une autre
application qui est dans le viseur de
washington c'est l'application oui chat
mais ce dimanche une juge californienne
a suspendu l'interdiction de
téléchargement qui avait aussi été
déclarée par donald trump
donc c'est une bataille juridique aussi
oui disons que c'est le vrai truc c'est
que il comme nous en france les états
unis perdent de plus en plus la bataille
en termes d'innovation parce que même si
les gaffes à les gaffes âme même sont
très actifs mais ils peuvent pas tout
inventé parfois ils font des erreurs et
par foyer des sociétés qui émerge
ailleurs et qui sont aussi très
efficaces et donc c'est vrai que là
dessus
bah ce qui se passe c'est que on se
retrouve avec des produits qui marchent
puisqu'on est dans un monde globalisé et
donc ses produits marchent aux états
unis
et il aimerait que des sociétés on va
dire plus proche d'eux et surtout je
pense qu'ils puissent paradoxalement
plus facilement surveiller parce que je
pense aux siens d coeur du problème de
tik tok c'était la fameuse mobilisation
contre le meeting de trump à tulsa et le
fait que les renseignements américains
ne peuvent pas surveiller facilement
je rappelle vous avez réservé des places
pour le meeting ses militants elle
n'était pas allée donc ce qu'ils avaient
fait que les rangs étaient quasiment
vides en tout à fait et je pense
d'ailleurs parce que pour pas se leurrer
on sait avec les les cas de wikileaks et
les révélations des douars snowdon toute
entreprise de communication américaine a
vocation à être contrôlée par le
département d'état d'une manière ou
d'une autre pour pouvoir intégrer ses
outils de surveillance dogbé lors qu'un
outil de communication de masse échappe
aux services de renseignements
américains ça leur pose un problème même
si c'est tout y est anodin il est à mon
sens le cas type top surtout en campagne
électorale merci beaucoup
pedro guana neto d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france